welcome to this video
yeah something a bit out of the ordinary
doing a cubit singh video again hoping
for a longer keep it singh session here
starting with rossovich yeah black play
a Kogi Roy we have to that's Alexander
Milosevic well-known Russian Grand
Master and very entertaining player
usually quite yeah cried out for the
attack out of the time yeah let's see
what we get here he's playing three
minutes here on the ICC playing against
GM with an Icelandic fly crosses
Norwegian no no way I'm sorry um yeah
you never know people choose the
Norwegian flag nowadays quite often for
quite obvious reasons so a very Kartik
game roster which is an exchange up this
was coming out of a Sicilian defense we
have a GM Yan what's a duck Heffernan so
it's obviously am an alias not the real
name yeah what do we got here three
minute chest they both have about the
same clock yeah clock time left and it's
total chaos like as an exchange up but
lost one pawn so nothing much is clear
yeah it's very very complicated and yeah
we can be curious how this is going to
end in three minutes yes obviously the
speed is very important even more so
than in five minutes yeah white has
transferred is Knight to f5 maybe hoping
for some sacrifice on the King but black
has an attack on his own yeah with a
three yeah this is a good disturbing
move you don't want to take with the
bishop it belongs on the long diagonal
and Queen takes is probably hit by route
ahead I guess now black is probably
objectively close to winning but as
usual in this very quick blitz time
control it's tricky
Bishop III they also might be Queen a5
that looks quite decent yeah here ookay
aid was what I was thinking but maybe
there's something better no he went for
that Queen age 3 and here's the big
counter-attack Bishop takes d5 though
huh probably he will take on b2 and just
claim that this attack will we win or
Bishop g5 okay 96 mate check so black it
really has to be oh yeah that's nice
yeah Knight f4 with the tempo winning a
tempo on the Queen and preventing not g6
mate very strong move ok 93 double check
was the big threat and when I was yeah
c4 was interesting pawn takes 93 so
black black has a strong attack but
white is kind of holding on he managed
to not get shake made it that's quite
nice but yeah c1 queen is winning I
didn't do that okay this is this is
winning as well I guess but not so clear
c1 Queen was a bit bit clearer even
surprised that he didn't do that huh
maybe it's this holding check it's not
that easy I know it is easy yeah 12
seconds is really a little bit white
there's a little bit on the low side
time wise okay the darn the next game
directly after that Moro began playing
black against Pumbaa for 6-4 7-6 and we
have a nother Sicilian yeah the other
game the game that we saw first was also
sharp Sicilian and here we get a
kind of a closed Sicilian where Mauro is
playing tons of porn was that doesn't
look very healthy to be honest deform
was interesting hmm but that's also not
bad and trying to use this weekend c5
pawn you are not easy for black now to
develop smoothly maybe ninety seven and
castles coming hmm yeah tricky position
but I like black now black looks okay he
has a very simple plan a5 and before
winning the bishop and this is not so
easy to play for white it's not so clear
what white is doing the knight on d6
looks active but it has little squares
now it takes b5 where it's just a move
just attacking the east have night huh
why why is night b5 not possible hmm it
is possible
now I mean like at least has some open
files but objectively speaking this
isn't very good I guess but how does
white play this hmm
okay I see three making sure that
there's always a safe post for the
bishop on before but on the other hand
he weakens the whole Queen side a little
bit d3 and b2 yeah and Knight to d5
that's a good good way to play the right
bishop now yeah it has to go somewhere
there huh okay yeah f4 f4 is a
possibility the bishop does not have
many squares it can go to d4 like GF EF
bishop deform hmm but this is definitely
okay for black I am okay he wants to get
some tricks going maybe on the the long
diagonal yeah G for now is the threat
very nice very nicely played like has
gained quite a lot of space on the Kings
side yeah maybe just Knight f6 try to
get the d3 pawn voice there better move
probably is
I probably play this pedestrian at f6
but that's not a very dynamic solution
that's probably a better one hmm yeah
never I would have come up with that
move
never yeah but I think it just blunders
chief all right well but okay that's
interesting
maybe this whole procedure has
accelerated the whole the whole thing
and not sure it is certainly objectively
favorable for white yeah white is two
pawns up and black is not having enough
compensation but we're too smoky it is
still very murky hmm not sure about g4
that looks like it gives some very
decent counter play for black yes you
have to take that almost I don't see how
Mauro is not taking it um I had this
move for the Queen's e3 I just saw it
just as it was playing it this is maybe
possible hmm fringe III Queen G - it's
not leading to that much why does a ton
of pawns up and blacks rook doesn't have
any square on g5 check check hmm
Jack still kind of interesting
white sacrifice this bag I don't know if
it was necessary but now hmm oh all bets
are off I think
anything anything can happen here yeah
III for Queen III check or quince III
check very difficult to play yeah now
White has a spinning problem this knight
is pinned and it's deadly yeah
the White King position was was a huge
problem here now as much as it turned
out and yeah like his winning hammer
rossovich unless he's got into some time
he sure is four seconds up on the clock
so he should win queen is four was
eyeing the rook already but you tend to
just make moves now
yeah he will win this time or position
wait for things on time yeah that was
Mary murky certainly and up and down up
and down struggle then I'm hoping for
more games at the moment morass which is
playing quite a lot here on the ICC we
can also I can also check here if
there's something else going on that we
might keep its own let's see any
high-profile games going on not at the
moment
fortunately not no well-known players
also having a look out of course for
multicast I could actually put put him
on my notified list yeah I have any time
just for good measure
maybe he's online at some point yeah
multicast is a mysterious player it is
rumored to be magnus carlsen but this is
kind of yeah everybody likes the idea of
the world champion playing some blitz on
the internet and he certainly does on
the various accounts but not sure if
this is really multicast and what i do
know is that probably multicast is
really human this is what i heard from
various sources that it's definitely not
an engine yeah unfortunately mauro is
not playing so we can check if there's
some other game going on i want to have
a look at my wood nemesis mr. woody
gasps what is he doing yeah what a gas
is or like you've won us off one of the
most notorious time players on ICC and
my personal nemesis I have absolutely no
score against him
if the absolute worst squad I mean it's
even worse than against any other
Grandmaster whatever okay he has a yes
black here in this game and it's
challenge
no and it's it's fairly interesting
because the white player played some is
played D for this centric game this kind
of opening which is kind of hmm a little
bit dubious but at least it's kind of
non symmetrical all the gas is normally
playing the Berlin Wall and trades every
piece that he's able to trade um this
time this was not possible he's trying
to get Queens off of course as mentioned
he trades every piece um yeah
unfortunately morrow is not playing a
heavy amount follow so it here only gas
is probably winning the exchange with
Knight f2 after doing nothing beforehand
yeah I don't know how it does it check
okay c7 is hanging though this is not
super clear huh it's not so clear
no but Howard is right actually get to
the night it does not have squares but
he coming challenge come on what is this
thing here I'm going to decline us
simply don't know what this guy wants
yeah and the night is not easily won it
is trapped but it's not easily won okay
so what white could have done he could
have played rook g1 Knight f2 d2
actually just following this Knight
eternally maybe he's preparing that this
is at least a draw
no we can play look D one night f2 f1
and then the knight is trapped and wide
wins actually huh nice so this this guy
has an excellent chance here to beat mr.
what he does
gee I dunno I don't I simply cannot to
get that for I guess I don't know I'm
playing really bad chess against
okay well this is there something else
something a little bit more exciting
going when I'm checking but not at the
moment some water sorry yeah there's
nothing going on in terms of honey
kibitzing there's tons of gm's on as
usual but not something very exciting
really love to see a little bit more of
Norwich it's always interesting but at
the moment is taking a small break it
seems I keep following him so as soon as
he's starting a game we're going to see
that in this end game here White has
maintained kept his extra pawn but it is
not easy to win at all black's rook is
fairly active on g3 yeah why does
pushing his pawns gaining some space and
yeah it's very difficult to really make
some headway with the active rook I
think the most likely result is maybe a
draw maybe white should go look f6
something like that yeah he should play
rook f6 giving up the Jeep on for the e
pawn I don't see how else to play for
win in this position probably not
possible
yeah keeping an eye there on the ponds
black might play g4 trying to force a
passed pawn on the Kings side ultimately
leading to trades I think g4 is probably
happening but White has excellent
winning chance this year still I guess
thinking maybe draw but hey this is this
is still very problematic yeah yeah
white might pick up even more pawns King
b6 going for the b7 pawn really no way
to defend it but of course it's first
it's like to move the so hmm King b6 I
guess or rook h5 both moves come into
consideration very much yeah no white is
doing for this b7 pawn yeah I'll just be
five
b5 I guess
you know takes takes and yeah how does
wide win not sure that King b7s actually
enough yeah I think Luke age seven
should be played
taking be seven with the rook and then
going back to the H file ultimately the
two pawns will wind yeah and uh [ __ ]
resigned yeah white has achieved what I
cannot achieve beating the sky not sure
what I'm doing wrong against him my
score as mentioned is like super
terrible yeah we are unlucky there is
absolutely
there's no game happening here by mr.
Murrow Savage who else can we watch we
can watch mr. Goldman tear let's see
this observe government with white
Alexander Rustom of playing capital
Jesus Qasim Ghulam Ali and American fm
he's got the Icelandic flag probably
because he's currently playing the
Reykjavik open capital G I only played a
couple here and very reality but I think
rooster more we have for some games
against yeah I've got one out of eight I
got pretty good positions but I didn't
score in any way okay what do we have we
have six points five pawns White is a
pawn down so rooster mow is a little bit
in trouble he has no compensation for
the pawn whatsoever and black has a
great night there on d3 that looks kind
of problematic for white yeah black is
getting the king up maybe to e6 even to
d5 I would probably play rook t8 here
making sure that why does not sacrifi
but the exchange seconds nothing in
particular yeah you can play King e6 you
don't need to cover d3 you know I mean
he can it's not a mistake but white
wasn't threatening to SEC the exchange
yeah that looks like a very nice
position for Ghulam Ali black player
should win this game with some tricks
Bishop takes rook g8 is nice not limits
White's Bishop very much and maybe King
e6 f5 and then g4g for a form to get two
passes the only issue is that while
controls the age from I think not sure
about the timing of g5 maybe it was
better to play g5 at the moment where
you are quicker to occupy the h-file I
mean black is very much in good shape
but not sure if this was the most
precise way to do it check yeah here we
go the pawns are rolling very often
really them it's them the speed of the
pawns being decisive not so much the
count oh that was a it was once that was
a exchange and it was a it's a very
unlucky moment ready because what is
flex move now
white threatens to take I am okay maybe
this is the the move that needed to be
played
I came okay he did a really good job
there he had to play that otherwise in
other with other moves I'm not sure what
happens with the pawns but here this is
really winning for black the pawns will
do the the talking and the walking
hmm F - that's hmm
these bones are strong hmm touchdown
white resigns yep very nicely played you
buying Ghulam Ali what other games do we
have do we want to bore cells to death
again a little bit with mr. woody gasps
what do we have it's as usual equal
points yep and Queens are traded and we
have some kind of end game where he
slightly worse yeah that he's going to
win on time as usual yeah okay but maybe
maybe the white player can can't avoid
that he's slightly behind on the clock
which is slightly yeah it says something
else I really don't like so much to
watch three one ourself grind out his
end games um what else kind of looking
here nothing special that what about
not a game you're from roost him off
maybe our Ghulam Ali now not happening
there are some other guys here I really
don't know here was that let's see here
oh that's bullets no no bullet what it
is a bit too quick for me I can do
commentary on that but that's also
another game hmm yeah that's not that
much action here at the moment on the
very high level that I'd like to like to
kibbutz on maybe what about this we're
here this GM duck hefferman we had one
game against him and against them
rossovich let's see what happened here
this is this guy kuba 476 which no name
no name I never played him is only
playing the quicker time controls never
five minutes so this sometimes happens
you have people here play quite a lot
but you don't really and yeah you don't
have played them simply because they
don't play five minutes in my case I
only play the five minute pool sometimes
I am playing the odd bullet game if I'm
really yeah and I can a very loose mood
but this rarely happens yeah yeah how it
isn't night before move black using the
pin 1 d2 is 92 good what is the problem
with that move it is good right and here
takes takes and yeah whoopsie 8 for
example looks quite good for rooks e1
black has a ton of pawns here how many
pawns does he have three pawns for the
piece and whites pieces are terribly
uncoordinated
yeah white white has no moon fear that's
really a bit unlucky the spot Brooksie
wanted threatened and I mean what what
is he supposed to play a knight b3 to
cover c1 black is just taking f4 I guess
and this gets ugly those three central
pawns
yeah and rook c2 and stuff white is not
in any way coordinated Jack yeah the
white knights they are not really doing
much not at all
yeah maybe now Knight c5 maybe you can
do something against a six Jack Ruby -
er what is to suggest that just trying
to pin down black has four points of the
piece and they are quite um fired once
Oh interesting so he got one back yeah
badru could be seven ninety seven and
then d5 or so this should be quite nice
for black especially in a practical game
yeah in analysis it's a different thing
where you can test all kinds of things
or even yeah use an engine in the
practical game with limited time the
pawns are just far more dangerous oh we
have a new game here
buy more oh okay so in this game here
black will win this endgame unless he
loses on time so let's go back to murasa
which is really the most fun to watch
okay h3 what kind of move is that so the
d4 okay we transpose back to an open
Sicilian with the red age three and a
four moves played Jelena eight years the
opponent probably not a no-name No
not a very frequently playing account
yeah Mauro is playing a rather strict
story strategic setup here against this
Sicilian going for long term expansion
on the Kings side maybe later with let's
say 93 Bishop b3 g hive this kind of
ideas or f4 that's the other idea yeah
like a b3 and maybe f4 later trying to
to break open their file yeah here we go
what black is lacking in this specific
position is direct play it's not quite
clear what its direct players see it
doesn't have any hmm
clear weak points to attack or yeah the
Knights on a5 and e5 if F is okay but
the a5 night is kind of just sitting
there all night f6 is going to win the
exchange and he quickly went for that
yeah and now it gets ugly b6 is hanging
and E 5 is not stable anymore Queen c7
maybe he looks good here jack or just
the Queen trade yeah sure that's also a
very pragmatic solution just trading
Queens yeah that's just an exchange and
end upon like has no compensation for
that here Scudder nice night on 5
resigns but that's never enough to
compensate the loss of the exchange
maybe we get a small series of games now
sometimes people play for a couple of
minutes and they take a small break and
then continue a little bit at least
that's how I'm doing it if I'm playing
some games in a row going to play good
couple then get something to drink and
then continue or get some snack or
whatever yeah we hope that he is
continuing
switching to a new or a different game
let's say and then switching right back
in case he starts some a new game yeah
that's also quite a number of bullet
games going on this is actually
something that I wanted to ask I
recognized that here a friend of mine
John Bartholomew who was Chandler's also
quite worth watching um
he's also uploading a number of bullet
games per day yeah like ten games or so
makes making a 2025 minute video with
some bullet games I was wondering if
this is something that you would be
interested in from time to time I'm not
a great bullet player but I can do it
and it might be a change of pace once in
a while it's not going to be a regular
feature but I was thinking that this is
something that I could do from time to
time if you have an opinion about that
please let me know
should I play the occasional little
bullet session yeah is it something that
would would be a in addition to the
channel that is worth watching yeah it
doesn't seem that Mauro is playing that
many games yeah okay yeah I'm going to
switch to another one huh
okay but they have a look again at all
he goes only gasps with white playing
cassoulet and this can tell you this
from the Catalan that is what is playing
all the time and yeah that's not bad
Kevon Asaf has a slight advantage rook
f1 is a move that
I don't understand why look everyone I
don't know but now we get a new moral
game that's more interesting anyway
playing shawshank an 87 me now Gatsby no
Russ
this is Lithuania okay we have a reverse
Sicilian yeah the English opening and
it's really a reversed Sicilian set up
here with III and so on
this is interesting white might play
with Bishop d3 here not with D for you
should to d3 okay
that's also of course playable yeah not
a bad position black normally after for
e3 doesn't react with d5 as he did but
with Bishop before and here I think
white is in quite decent shape
it's got good central play and well it's
formal structure is not great but f5 is
not a pawn move that is so so helpful
you know just castling here maybe Bishop
a3 Queen b3 check okay this check for us
and then look do you wanna that's that's
better of course why this may be able to
make sure that black get some kind of a
backward pawn on d6 yeah Bishop d6 here
woop TC group d6 Queen d6 rook t1 that
didn't happen black he kept one look on
they have six rook and now white is
going to pile up on the D pawn yeah
that's a nice position maybe Bishop d5
Trading this yep and now just piling up
on the default Queen d2 for example
Queen b3 those kind of moves
yeah d3 is of course also good just
making sure that you're not getting back
rank made it okay the taking and right
this is a self Pena on the rook woo b5
wasn't a very successful idea now simply
why does a pawn up ante
controls the position a forum Bishop
back and then Luke takes d6 and that's
it basically
yeahjust bishop react to f3 or something
and then Luke takes the six is going to
hit
yeah that's a nice technical game three
six yes hmm
yeah White has two pawns and especially
better piece coordination look at this
really bad Bishop on EA that had
absolutely no square to go to and yeah
Bishop we should be for not yet
wandering but this is better giving this
check and now Bishop before we win
probably yeah it will win Bishop before
I sorry I'm blundering huh Bishop before
Queen takes before late at the day not a
good idea
okay prepares it and wants to play
Bishop to e4 check the next move why is
black not checking
yeah it was for sexually Queen a one
check hmm okay for Bishop takes before
that check that's funny
check yeah and see yeah it's a very nice
fighting effort but black okay six now
and then you march your pawns yeah it is
a win but it was not a bad not a bad
effort by black King King up now up to
g6 and the pawns will promote yeah King
e4g for f5 h4 h5 and so on it's very
easy in fact the problem is that black's
pawn age five or g5 that black's pawn is
so far back it's absolutely not
effective do i can just push with this
whole check on a model forward
yeah can yeah you can switch now with
the rookie exactly check and he six
that's it is haven't made rupee eight
rupees check me exactly see seven media
quite quite neat yeah that was a was a
nice game not difficult after black
played b5 here this this blunder yeah
running into into this funny hit self in
it was was basically over
yeah nice veneer for murasa which okay
I'm hoping that he's starting a new game
rather quickly and we're not going to
wait for too long he's playing in the
three minute for three minute polish you
really where you get rather get
opposition opponents rather quickly
it's um almost as quick as the five
minute pool maybe it's about the same
not quite sure it's probably comparable
there are some people who really prefer
the three-minute time controller which
is of course valid in online chess you
get in far more moves then let's say
three minute in over the board blitz you
know so I mean my favorite time control
three plus one is not played
unfortunately this is I think three plus
one is very nice in online chess it is
quick it doesn't take a long time it's
not longer than five minutes as normally
and I mean if you play three plus one
120 moves would be the equivalent of a
full five-minute game and you don't get
120 moves that often so it is quick one
second per move is totally enough to
play dead end games yeah to a draw or
win the easily winning ones it's not
really changing the pace of blitz chess
a lot 3+1 and you don't get this useless
rookie against rookie stuff yeah it
looks like Morris
playing that many games here and if it's
mostly about waiting doesn't make much
sense I can never look again at mr. only
Gus yeah is playing mega Jet Set here
what's the name exactly zombie ones ow
maybe he can beat and now but no Mauro
is starting in the game okay
he's playing but it takes a while okay
it's not Blacky against Gabon that is no
guru new Raya yeah this guy is pretty
high rated and I have a terrible score
against him in where exactly oh I have
various time control what's here
actually fall out of eleven okay so we
have a what is this actually this was a
weird London sister and Mauro is a pawn
down yeah that's true but he's got the
bishop pair oh okay yeah I think black
has slight compensation it is not
totally clear if it is enough but it's
not bad
it's not enough really but white is not
easily doing something with this extra
pawn let's say yeah if black just
develops quickly knight c6 Bishop f5
maybe Queenie sixes move trying to to
spoil any castling rights but okay is
just going for this is also good yeah
Knight 2 D 3 what black hands does he
has a very nice open Bishop diagonal the
bishop is looking at the c3 pawn which
is not great but it makes moving the
whole Queens are difficult yeah like B 3
C 4 those kind of moves are not possible
black has some piece pressure on the
Queen side
it's not clear how wide is going to
continue here there are some neat little
ideas maybe let's say Queenie - with a
bishop at 5d3
yeah here moves like Knight a 4 on 93
come into consideration of course let's
see what he's doing one of the two I
guess I mean not necessarily you can
yeah you can do that yeah ok that's
actually a good move good tactical move
winning back the pawn almost if you go
Knight B 3 a B 3 Queen B 3 there is a 7
hanging so not not so clear if you want
that but you can take and maybe should
be six maybe okay it's going for that
for this trading sequence Knight g5 was
also interesting I guess but why the
tries to trade Queens yeah I think like
hmm is it okay is this okay maybe it is
okay I mean black has the bishop an and
the double pawn now is this double death
pawn I'm sorry the extra pawn is the
double F pawn which is not that
troublesome now like black is quite
active him
yeah I think black isn't came it
shouldn't be anything dramatic at all oh
now it might be dramatic if the rook
moves there's twin f2 and mate so black
seems to pick up the exchange maybe yeah
Quincy won or something that's just
roopd aid yeah that looks good yeah it
looks good for more oh and also 30
seconds ahead on the clock
you should manage to to win him unless
he's losing the whole queenside this
could happen here yeah that all plants
going to be cleared black is very
quickly this room should be six year for
route c7 I guess or look ASM groups III
and black invades now that that
Blackwell William probably also on time
but the position also should be
ultimately good ruku c7 maybe just keep
the pawn f4 this rook age to tear just
rupee to and black keeps dominating yeah
that's nice why white has no real play
here if everything else fails you just
play King f8 e 76 this kind of thing
okay he tries to get rid of the e pawn
immediately and also not bad at all and
now the King James up King e5 qinger for
invasion time yeah it's an easy win for
black now
there maybe just king looking for Jack I
can give this check but it doesn't help
much
King age 3 I guess also only be careful
not to run into some silly kind of self
media rookie 3 H 3 yeah me and not even
that is a mate but you know what I mean
sometimes you're kind of killing
yourself with some some stupid moves
this is what he has what he has to avoid
here why doesn't even have any
meaningful check its last four things on
time now that was a nice win here by
Morel he was a pawn down but had nice
compensation and why it really had
nothing at the end there to show for his
exchange that he lost later with this
Bishop c4 idea yeah okay I'm going to
call it quits now here it's not quite
clear how many games Rose which is going
to play we got some action out of this I
hope you enjoyed it thanks for watching